[Music]
so we're gonna talk about cloud native
computing what's cloud native computing
it's all of these words let's highlight
some of the ones that are most
interesting so cloud native computing is
an approach to computing that
prioritizes things like containerization
immutable infrastructure declarative API
is loose coupling and this allows you to
have principles like observability
automation and really good
predictability these are the
characteristics that are embedded in
modern infrastructure and are
particularly exemplified by kubernetes
who here has heard of kubernetes I think
good thanks for being awake for at least
part of the last couple days all right
so modern infrastructure has been about
the evolution from treating servers like
pets to treating them like cattle and
that's the benefit of using a cloud
infrastructure like Google compute
engine
but cattle are still solid substantial
long-lived things you can say look at
that cow over there that one by the
fence you know that one with a sarcastic
look in her eyes but with the next wave
of computing things like infrastructure
you can't really grab a hold of servers
like cattle are the nodes the containers
the addresses the pods they all blinking
and out of existence and they're really
only comprehensible as a collective it's
less like cattle and it's more like a
big frothing mass of micro organisms but
you know what you get from a big frothy
mass of micro organisms beer
so modern infrastructure is great but
it's very different from the traditional
ways of doing computing so now let's
take a look at how we've been doing to
see ICD here are some of the models that
describe a typical C ICD systems so
first we have the Rube Goldberg machine
you push a button here and that
schedules a job there and that opens a
socket over there and that sends an XML
message over to that thing which writes
generated code onto a floppy and you
give it to the intern and she runs it
across the street and puts it in the
mainframe and catapults it up onto prod
and you know what it works but these
things are kind of like Heisenberg
property if you peel back and try and
look at it yeah oh no never mind never
mind walking away so it's very fragile
here's of course the Frankenstein model
it's been cobbled together and it's
one-of-a-kind beautiful really in its
way
and this guy he's gonna lurch and lumber
slow perhaps but steady to get your
stuff from source to prod and everyone's
from one of his arms will fall off but
if you know where to find dr.
Frankenstein you can call him up and
he'll stitch that arm back on and of
course the model of the hairball so we
use these terms to describe RC ICD
systems and we use them affectionately
because we crafted them and we know all
their quirks but let's face it these
systems are pets in fact this is exactly
what my cat looks like when I talk to
customers about the setups they're doing
I often hear things like we have one big
server and only Susan is allowed to
touch it or we upgraded our system and
now we can run two simultaneous tests or
we have one staging environment and the
DBAs are always messing it up this
approach it has worked sorta for a long
time but now that we move to a new kind
of infrastructure we need to change how
we do C ICD we need cloud native C ICD
so right now we as an industry are at
the beginning of a major effort to
establish a new kind of C ICD this is an
effort to modernize software delivery to
take advantage of all the benefits of
cloud computing so that we can get
things like speed scalability
portability and improved quality last
month the Linux Foundation announced the
continuous delivery foundation or CDF
this is a sister project to the cloud
native computing
datian the goal of the CDF is to
evangelize the icd define best practices
and support collaboration between
practitioners and vendors these are the
premier members of the CDF and they
include as you can see big tech
companies see ICD veterans and some
customers who are active and proactive
in CI CD like Netflix there's also a lot
of vendors in that are part of the
general member space and a lot of
well-known CI CD tools are in that space
so a lot of the industry is coming
together here to define a next
generation so the CD f's approach is
heavily deformed by kubernetes
kubernetes says knocked unlocked a new
level of runtime security and
portability and scalability so with the
CIC with the CDF we're bringing those
things to CI CD and we're embedding best
practices so that we get
containerization immutable
infrastructure declarative API is all
that good modern stuff the initial
projects in the cdf are Jenkins Jenkins
X spinnaker and Tecton CDF fosters
community communication between these
projects so that we get interoperability
and we establish shared best practices
let's take a closer look at Jenkins X
Jenkins X bundles together several
best-of-breed open source technologies
things like Jenkins helm scaffold prowl
these are all really cool open source
projects that do specific things
Jenkins X puts them together into a
pre-wired batteries included solution
based on modern best practices and it
provides an on-ramp to cloud native CI
CD while maintaining a lot of that user
experience you're familiar with from
Jenkins so let's see it in action ok so
I have here running an application you
can see I have this is a very
interesting game which is shooting
lasers to cut around right I could be
playing this forever it's a lot of fun
and I have it running here in the
staging environment and they have the
same application
refresh it in production and you can see
here at the bottom the version and the
region and the commit that is being used
to build these applications of this is
134 in production
I have 134 also in staging so let's say
what is my typical development workflow
I have my project ingot hub and I want
to implement the change right seems that
shooting lasers to calculus is not very
environmentally friendly so instead
we're going to make a change to make
this more politically correct so I could
do this from from my from my machine I'm
going to just edit the file here and
edit this file I'm going to make a small
change game too and I'm going to say no
lasers no I want to create a pull
request and these would go through my
typical process of code review that
we're going to skip today because I know
this is going to work for sure so what's
gonna happen is if you see here I have a
bot that is commented has commented and
my pull request it's basically telling
me this pull request is not a proof this
is a bot that is included in Jenkins X
and I can talk to this pot and I can say
things very important things like me and
my bot is gonna is gonna answer back to
me so I can do I can talk to this but
there are several commands this is you
seem proud this is a project from
kubernetes itself that they use for CI
CBL of kubernetes so this is basically
listening to webhook events and doing
things you can write your own plugins
and if you can see here there is a
serverless Jenkins and I'm gonna talk a
little bit about that so
and tight checks that are still running
so if I go to my command line and seen
this I wanna I want to check the logs so
I can see the logs of my of the build of
this pull request happening in
kubernetes so this is using several as
Jenkins which is a project that we
created that allows you to have several
nests built so every time there's a web
hook event coming in to Jenkins X it
will create a new pot for Jenkins so
it's a small Jenkins server running that
it doesn't it only takes a few seconds
to start so it's not the whole thing you
learn edu I do - neither all extra
things and what is going to happen it's
going to create a path run that and at
the end of the build is going to
disappear so you have two options on
Jenkins X you have the option to have a
static master like the typical junkets
that you know and you have the
serverless option and this is gonna be
using pretty soon we're ready
integrating Tecton if you heard about
Tecton the project it was Anna I was
talked about in other sessions it's
coming from K native built and it's
basically allowing you to use containers
in your in your bill pipeline so let me
get back to here this is still pending
we can take a look at why okay okay this
is still anything for some reason we can
check the last okay well this is still
maybe my cluster is out to scaling what
may be happening is that my desire has
triggered my clustered auto scale so in
it error okay so my build did fail I can
see this in the logs here connection
timeout that's not great so something
happened here so my maybe you can see
that it's a real demo because it has
failed
I can I think I can rerun this and I can
tell to run it again that was some
connection issue but in the meantime I
can continue talking of it this is stop
calling running again you can see here
the logs from your Jenkins pipeline so
this is will be the same thing that
you've seen and traditional Jenkins in
your console output so if we go to the
previous one it's what it's doing is
this is a golang application so it's
building the goaling application it you
see is a scaffold to create the docker
image you can see here the logs for the
docker image build and then it's pushing
the docker image to a private repository
before deploying it to governor's and
it's also the plot creating the helm
chart and deploying the helm chart
because everything in Jenkins X runs a
ham chart and it helps you specifically
if you have kubernetes applications it
helps you have really standardized stack
and pipeline for home tarts and
kubernetes apps so this is running make
now well this is running I'll show you
what's running behind the scenes so this
is run in a cluster in GAE I have two
clusters running
okay this is two machines right now I
have it is done out to scale so it's
here's how to scaling a song so what
happens is with the combination of these
serverless Jenkins and out scaling on GK
the more jobs I have the more bills I
have the the cluster is going to expand
but it's also going to contract when
there's no jobs running so I get this
LST CDM kind of pea spur use that you
would want to ask a level CI CD okay so
this is still running before I I kind of
skip the kind of the questions that I
always ask raise your hand if you're
using Jenkins please yes a lot of people
with using kubernetes a lot of people
who is using Yankees on kubernetes just
some people okay so this is a step
forward the the other way you can run
you can run traditional Jenkins with
kubernetes trading agents on pots
that's the plugging I started a few
years ago and this is going the next
step which is basically you Genki
surplus you don't even need to run the
Jenkins master all the time so if this
works for you and this is not working I
think this is failing in the same step
okay so let's switch to another cluster
I have and and see if that works there
there's some connection going on so I'm
gonna do the same thing I'm gonna add it
is I'm gonna create a pull request
no lasers so this is another project
that I have in a different cluster
because demos and this should trigger
the same thing if this doesn't work here
oh no it felt okay so you cannot be
reached oh oh thinking sex to tell you
is down wow I didn't expect that okay
well that's gonna be hard to fix nuts
alright so let me let me talk through
this and hopefully things will fix
themselves and so the other thing
because I'm running this in gke I get
all the locks from my deke containers on
my stock driver so I can filter for them
I can see the same things you can see in
the console or I could see in the
Jenkins output you can see them in in a
star driver so you can see that the same
error is here so this is very cool
because then you have this permanent
storage and you can use a stock driver
to just query it use the api's build
applications on top of that and do any
sort of integration you want and we have
created also at Chloe's IUI so you can
go and and see what's running on staging
and production environments in Jenkins X
Jenkins X by default creates namespaces
for different environments so you get
the staging you get production and the
interesting thing is that you get one
full request environment for each pull
request so if I go to a previous to a
previous pull request
put requests here let's go to one that
is closed here so when my bill succeeds
what it's telling me is basically your
pull request is available in this
preview environment so this is a
namespace and kubernetes and it doesn't
interfere with my staging home or
production environments so I could click
here the link doesn't work now because
this was deleted before but this would
send me to my application my helm chart
deployed into a preview environment the
separate foreigners namespace so I can
see my pull request in action and before
merging it into master and ok this is
running and this is not going to work
today
all right let's let's trigger it again
and see
yeah so I get if the test fails I get
the details also my body's it's all chat
ups where your body's talking to you and
you can do this these commands so I was
talking about environments staging and
production so if I run GX get let me
just cube if i do GX get environments i
see that i have a staging i have
production and I have to assign github
repositories for each of them so if I go
to staging what I can see here is my
environment has a channel file where
it's basically saying what applications
do I have deployed into this environment
so this is get-ups it's my environment
much what is storing it and whenever I
want to make a change to my environments
I change it in git and that triggers the
change in the cluster so if my if my
cluster disappears and I lose all the
data of what applications I have the
plate or anything I could always come
here and and say you know this is the
source of truth for my cluster and I can
reinstall everything based on this file
so I don't have to you don't touch your
cluster everything is going through get
and get triggers the build and the
pipeline and that ends in your in the
cluster state with applications that you
want so if for the staging repository
what Jenkins X does is that
automatically
upgrades your application to the latest
in master so when I immerse my pull
request is going to trigger a build and
create a new home chart version and
drinking sex is going to come here and
say in the staging
and update the version so all these full
requests are also generated by Jenkins X
so it's a it will say promote crow
hunter to version 134 and this will go
automatically through the build and this
is a very simple pull request that
Jenkins X does which is saying change
the version 133 to 134 so this is done
automatically stating is always matching
what you have in your master branch the
other thing I have have the same
equivalent thing for a production
environment so if I run let me see if I
promote an application is going to come
here and because its production I have
to manually promote it using a command
and it will come here make an update to
the git repository and trigger the
pipeline so if this doesn't work I'm
going to skip through this and show you
the promotion so this is still failing
because this site is down so let's do
something else I can get the
applications I have running in my
cluster they execute applications they
have 0 0 134 in both staging and
production what I'm going to do is I'm
gonna promote an older version that is
already built this is probably going to
be
I'm gonna promote 133 and let's see
what's in there so I can do JX promote
croc hunter drinking sex justice version
zero zero 133 does the environment
production and what this is going to do
is going to create that pull request
where it goes to production and says you
know instead of 134 put 131 33 and while
this is running let me show you
something else when I leave this running
here to not miss the locks okay so this
is doing it created a pull request so
this is a pull request against my
production environment as you can see
this is done automatically after I did
the DX promote the file changes instead
instead of 134 go to one air deploy 133
in production and this is running the
build they build has succeeded it was
merged and now is going to be deployed
to to production environment so I can
see the logs of the build and all that
now in the until recently what this
happened well what this was doing was
just updating the application so do
immediately get one the version you
promote into into production environment
one thing I've been working on is to do
progressive delivery cannery deployments
are progressive deliver encompasses like
canary deployments Bluegreen deployments
things like that so basically you don't
want to deploy new versions to everybody
of all your users because you don't know
if he's gonna break something
you want to deploy to a subset of users
so this is the tip
stuff that Netflix Facebook Google does
so what we are doing and what I have
enabled in this project and is exactly
that canary deployments so I have
basically Jenkins X has the concept of
applications dinkus X applications or
extension points and one of them is
flagger so flagger is a project that
will do these cannery deployments for
you and this is using East EO and
Prometheus metrics so what we're going
to see here is that flagger detects
there's a new change a change to my
deployment coronaries and instead of
treating the whole traffic to it is
going to create the easier deployment
configuration necessary to shift traffic
a little at a time so what we're gonna
do
I have it configure is gonna do every
minute is going to shift 10% of the
traffic so 10 20 30 40 and 50 and then
at 50 is gonna deploy to everybody else
so we're gonna see that in the loads in
a second I also have it comes with a
graph on a dashboard here
have to forward the port where I can see
the incoming the new version the system
version the new version the qunari
I can see the CPU request the the CPU
uses the requests that are incoming and
I'm going to generate some traffic so it
gets some noise here this is basically
hitting the application printing the
return code and what version and you can
see that some of them are returning 133
and some of them are returning 134 so
it's already splitting the traffic and
in the logs I see here advanced GX
production wait
10 so that means 10% of the traffic is
going to the canary which so I have 134
deploy the canary I'm doing it the
reverse so it's 133 so if i refresh I'm
getting 134 133 depending on on this
balancing of that east you is doing and
I should get some traffic now here yeah
so the primary is the existing the
previous version canary is the version
I'm deploying so I can see the success
right
a type of all sorts of metrics you can
add all these metrics you don't have to
touch your application for to do
anything really this is automatically
done with East here so it is basically
prof seeing all the requests to this
application automatically it's sending
the metrics to Prometheus so you get
status calls you get response time and
does those are the two metrics I'm
checking here but you could still adds
more metrics and you could create your
own metrics but for this you don't need
to touch your application at all so
what's going to happen also okay this is
advancing
is 20 is 30% before this rolls out
completely if I do it quickly enough I
will show you how the how we can
automatically detect that the new
version is having issues and roll it and
how this is gonna roll it back without
you having to do anything so let me open
[Music]
and I will explain this in a second what
I'm going to do my application I have a
couple of a special URLs that are going
to return 500 errors and delays so I'm
gonna force errors into my application
to see how how Jenkins X is going to
handle those flagger is going to handle
those and roll by my application
automatically so I need to heat
I'm I'm gonna run this I need to run
this from inside the cluster and what
I'm doing here is creating a deaf but
Jenkins X has this idea of their pots
which are basically containers the
coronary spots that have a stack for
instance so you can choose i chose our
goal line both death pot so it's
creating a pot and giving me a shell
into it so i can run whatever
development environment commands that i
want i'll show you in a second I need
just need to make it fail before it
finished deploying or I have to start it
again which is too late okay it's too
late so it went up to 50% this is good
I'll show you the whole thing
one is succeeding the one is failing so
it went to 50% and basically now all the
traffic is going to the version I have
promoted and let's see the curl you see
all the requests are getting version 133
so which was the one I was deploying and
if I go here to my east EO gateway yeah
I'm getting version 133 and in version
133 well this is because I couldn't make
the change this is not the one I wanted
to show but you see that the release is
133 and it's a different commit while in
a staging I have 130 for a stage in the
same hasn't changed so I'm going to do
the promotion again I'm gonna say okay I
want to promote JX get applications yes
promote that's the sperm so I'm gonna
promote 134 instead of 133 environment
production okay so this is going to do
the same thing again but changing the
version right so it has created a pull
request same thing github repository and
this is going to be automatically tested
and deployed yes and in a second this
will be up so I was here my left pod was
created so I can start injecting errors
so this is not just for error so let me
so I'm creating the despot again so you
see I have different stacks I have go I
have maven I have no Jes and this is
reusing the one I created the other
feature it has it has the
synchronization so this should have work
okay so this is copying automatically
copying my local context to the report
to the remote pot so if I go I'm running
out of consoles here yes and I touch
touch a file I'm in my local machine I
can go to the remote machine my test
file is here so this allows you to edit
your files work on your development
machine change files do whatever you
want use your ID and this gets
automatically sync to kubernetes and in
the remote machine what I can do I can
do make I can do a docker bill I can do
a hometown bill if I want with the
benefit that is this is all running
remotely so this is running on Google
is using Google internet connection
which is going to be a lot faster than
uploading doctor images from my
development machine to
coronaries cluster and then doing it so
this helps you using the remote using
the cloud to do the things that are
heavier for your development environment
so let's try this again
okay so flagger has now detected that
there's a new revision say it's starting
again the cannery process and in the
second is going to shift 10% of the
traffic and we can see it here you can
see that after the cannery deployment
before they need the cannery version is
not getting any traffic that's a scale
down and all the traffic is shift to the
the cannery is moved into production and
all the traffic is shipped to the new
version and the cannery is stopped so
it's all on demand based on when the
canary process happens okay so I'm
getting 10% of the traffic now to the my
canary and this is starting to pick up
there's some this should be starting in
a second there is some getting some
traffic than the new version what i'm
going to do is force the failure and and
you see there's some some of them are
getting 134 some of them most of them
are nearing 133 and i'm gonna for some
here yes i'm gonna force errors so i'm
gonna force my application to return 500
errors and let's see what happens so
this is going to start showing that the
success rate is dropping
and flagger is gonna detect that and do
it the rollback automatically okay so
this access right is falling and I think
I have it configure I'm gonna show you
the configuration because this is gonna
take a little bit okay yeah so this is a
Jamel file that includes in my home
charts I'm saying canary is enabled
these are the hosts that are used for is
tio and this is the canary analysis
which is the important piece so step
weight is the 10% I'm increasing up to
50% that's their steps I want I'm saying
do it every 60 seconds and threshold is
how many times can the matrix fail
before I do the rollback so if the
matrix fell three times do the rollback
and the matrix that I'm using is two
matrix that are sent by E steel I don't
have to do anything in my application
so I'm saying you know every 60 seconds
check the requestor sex rate and make
sure it's over 99% and make sure that
the seconds the duration of the request
is under 500 milliseconds so check these
two metrics and if they fail do the
rollback that's how what I have
configure and this one this one and you
can see here can you see it in the back
what's happening here is halt halt
advancement because the success right
rate is 93% which is less than the 99%
that I had set in my configuration and
the second time is out now it's 49%
which still fails and the third time is
now 44 percent so this should
automatically roll it back in a second
because it has noticed that the new
version the canary version is failing
and I can go back to refiner
there's the success right it's going
really really down I can also get these
logs again the flagger logs you can get
them in a stock driver okay so there it
is the Hult have the production
deployment so you can get all this
information here and in a second or more
okay if I say the sooner I said this
really happens yeah so production fail
checks threshold rich three cannery fail
scaling down my canary deployment in
production if I go to my curl I see that
now everything is returning 133 so it's
all rolled back and my canary should
stop getting traffic now because it has
been rolled back so it's going back to
the to the previous version so I think
well if you want to get take a look at
the application that's the does the
github repo and just you can see how the
con charts are configured
one thing I didn't mention I'm just
gonna show it now other things that you
can do with drinking sex you can do JX
create Quick Start it's a very easy way
to start creating kubernetes
applications so I'm going to create demo
next and I can choose from one of the
existing templates so I can create an
Android application a goal and I know
the HTTP spring boots so let's create a
spring boot application yes yes so it
has this has created the scaffolding for
me let's go to my github repo so you see
it has my it has a docker file yeah it
has a Jenkins file it has my home charts
I'm just created for a specific type of
application and I have the deployment
for kubernetes the service everything is
already configure so this is a very nice
way to start with you're creating
applications and drinking sex
[Music]